hi welcome super excited to be here in
the last few years pandas APN spark has
been growing out of bounds today we will
talk about it and see how it helps scale
data science
who are we
I'm serong
my co-speaker kakuya we are both working
at databricks and we are retainers of
pandas on spark
I'm a spark committer and focusing on
Pathmark tacos is a spectrometer and PMC
member focusing on spark SQL and
Passback
shortly about data breaks
we are the data and AI company
we are the inventor and Pioneer of the
data lake house
the lake horse is a new paradigm it has
been invented by us and adopted by the
market
we are recognized by leaders like
Gartner in both dbms and data science
and machine learning platforms
databricks was founded by creators of
Highly Successful open source data
projects now you can think about data
Lake Apache spark and ml flow
currently we have
4500 employees across the globe
was of course the most important thing
is that we have adopted by almost every
industry we have over 7 000 customers
all around the world
and we are having
the agenda of our talk will be first uh
very quick introduction to pandas spark
and pandas on spark
second uh deep back into pandas and
Sparks internal we will talk about the
internal frame and Catalyst Optimizer of
dark circle
third
an example showing how pandas and Spark
helps scale data science
and a brief performance comparison
against pandas
last we'll see the future of pandas and
Spark
okay let's start from the basics to
understand pandas on spark let's see
what pandas API is
python data science has been like has
exploded over the last few years
pandas is the de facto standard tool for
data manipulation and data analysis in
Python
it is integrated into python data
science ecosystem
which consists of numpy and Matt poly
for example
and it works on a single node only
Apache spark is the de facto unified
engine for large-scale data analytics it
supports streaming ETL and machine
learning and so on is integrated into
ecosystem which consists of DBT and
parquet for example
and it works on a single note or a
cluster in a distributed manner
past Arc is the python API for Apache
Spark
is intuitive that pandas on spark
implements pandas API on top of spark
specifically as shown on the right
pandas APN spark interacts with spark
Circle which runs on top of spark core
pandas on spark originates from coalesce
and becomes part of Apache spark in 3.2
release
it scales of penance workloads and makes
pandas users immediately productive with
spark
it also enhances Passback users
productivity through Panda slag
functions
as shown on the right
spark Circle also has data frame API
so what's the difference between
appendix and Spark frame and a password
frame
first a pandas on spark free mimics a
pandas data frame and it implements
pandas API
a pass Mark frame is more compliant with
relations or tables in a relational
database and supports relational
operations
second appendix on spark frame
implements identifiers for both rows and
columns
called indexes following pandas
whereas a pass Mark frame supports
column identifiers only
third appendix and Spark frame is
mutable following pandas
but a Passback frame is immutable
however like both frames share the same
execution engine the Run of spark
sequels especially the Catalyst of
tomato
we'll talk about it in the next section
now let's briefly talk about the
internal of pandas on spark
we will focus on the internal frame and
Catalyst Optimizer from spark SQL
afraid a series or an index in panda
sunspark is backed by a Passback frame
we've seen the differences between a
pandasa spark frame and a Passback frame
now let's see how an internal frame
fills the gap
an internal frame mainly consists of a
past spark frame pass by columns
names and types of index columns and
data columns separate tests separately
here the data types of columns include
pandas details and Spark data tabs
as the figure shows
appendix on spark free
Associates with an internal frame
which references a Pathmark data frame
the internal frame stores the metadata
as we mentioned just now
an API call against the pandas on spark
frame we'll copy the current
that copy the current internal frame
with the new state and update the
Passback data frame optionally
as we mentioned in the last section
pandas and Spark leverages the Catalyst
Optimizer of spark SQL
Catalyst has a framework for
representing trades and applying rules
to manipulate them
on top of this framework it has
libraries specific to relational query
processing and rules that handle
different phases of query execution such
physics include analysis logical
optimization physical planning and code
generation
first let's look at two heavily used
rules of The Logical optimization
the column pruning rule ensures to read
the necessary columns only
an example is as shown below
the original query is that we first read
a table r with five columns
then we run a filter over column C
finally we Group by column A
and get the sum of column B per group
here only three columns a b c are used
the column pruning will inject a project
before the filter
in this way the scan becomes more
efficient since we only have to read
three columns a b and c
foreign
rule pushes the filtering down to the
data source in this way the filtering
happens at a very low level rather than
deals with the entire data set
here is an example
the original query is that we first read
a table r
from parquet files with two columns A
and B
then we run a filter over each column
finally we sum up both columns
the predicate push down will push down
the filtering
and evaluate it against the metadata
stored in the parquet files
search metadata includes for example the
maximum and minimum value for column
chunk
in this way we can skip reading and
necessary data chunks
there are plenty of other optimization
rules for The Logical planning that now
let's move on to the physical planning
physical planning transforms logical
plans into executable physical plans
with the best physical strategy
here is a physical planning example
the query
joins table A and B
groups
by column A like sorry first it will
filters over column
B1 and then it goes by column A1 finally
selects column A1 and sum of column B1
the the green one is the logical plan
optimized by rules we mentioned just now
the planner
generates the physical plan in the red
color
note that the hash aggregate before the
shuffle is a partial aggregation
we are asked Iran after the shuffle is a
full aggregation
so our four aggregation requires all of
the data for one key to be together on
the same node before aggregation
as for the drawing selection there are
multiple drawing strategies here the
planner estimates
the like the filter on table B
and selects the broadcast drawing
broadcast hash drawing so like broadcast
has joined broadcast the filtered B
so we don't need to shuffle a
so that's a quick introduction of pandas
on spark internals now takuya will talk
about how we can scale data science with
pandas AP and Spark
I will leave it to you thank you
yep oh let me share my screen
yep uh thanks shiron for the uh
introduction of pandas API on spark and
it's internals
uh I'm Takia uh I'm gonna show a simple
example
uh and how Punk's API on spark can run
the existing pandas work Road faster
uh here's the example
uh there are three tables three data
frames uh the one is the master uh
customers
and two transactions orders and payments
uh the customer is almost static
compared to transactions and so let's
say it contains 100 roles now
the two transactions can be huge
we want to summarize the customer's
orders
uh the calculation is like this this
function works with both pandas and
pandas on Spock
it takes three arguments customers
orders and payments
uh they are pandas or pandas on spark
data flames
and contains the data stored as poke and
prep uh pre-processed a bit such as
relating renaming columns
the first part is calculating the oldest
and the most recent order date
and the number of orders for each
customer from orders table
doing Group by custom ID and then
aggregate over orders
the second part is calculating the total
amount for each customer
adjoining payments and orders then
grouping by customer ID and aggregating
the sum of amount
and finally joins the aggregated results
with the customers
now result will be like this
the aggregated and joined columns are
first order most recent order number of
orders and customer lifetime value
the number of rows is the same as
customers because the aggregated
Aggregates are grouped by customer ID
the overview of the calculation is like
this
there are two aggregations and three
joints
based on the settings let's take a look
at the performance comparison
at first I try to run the same query
against pandas and pandas on spunk on a
single node cluster where the spark is
launched on local mode
the node has a 34 30.5 gigabyte memory
and full course vcpu
the tables are the same as I described
before but the two transaction tables
have different sizes
the orders the order stable has about
1000 rows as a Baseline
and 10 times more rows 100 times more
roots and so on
the payments table also has about one
thousand roads as a Baseline and uh 10
times and 100 times likewise
so both loads are about 100
multiplied by uh n power of 10. where n
is from 1 to 7.
The Benchmark measures from Reading data
from the disk and then pre-proced a
pre-process and calculate
for the Panda's own spark it finally
calls two Pounders function to get the
results as Founders data frame to be
fair
so the results are Honda's data flame
for both pandas and pandas on spark
the measurement is until the
materialization
uh before the actual measurement uh run
twice for warm up and around 5 times for
the measurements
foreign
between pandas and pandas on stock
x-axis is the dead size and y-axis is
the duration in the
logarithmicity logarithmic scale
the shorter bar means that the execution
was faster
for the small data science funders can
run much faster for uh compared to spark
even in a single node spark needs some
preparations such as planning are needed
and the graph shows the overhead
but the larger the dead side becomes the
faster spawn can run
the threshold is between n equals 4 and
5 in this case
and also Panda scratched with um when n
equals 7 but spark still worked
foreign
next one is the performance compression
among different clusters and this is
only for pound uh Panasonic Spark
each node has the same amount of memory
and the same CPU settings as before
and this time the number of nodes is
different from 1 to 64.
the tables are the same and the orders
and payments are the largest size that
pandas was able to work with
as the same as before around two times
for warm up and five times for the
measurement
here's the result
x-axis is the number of nodes and y-axis
is the duration uh the same as before
a shorter bar means the execution was
faster
it shows that the more nose spark has
the faster it runs
the performance scales linearly
okay then let's see the planning
the analyst plan is the plan before the
optimization
there were 67 lines of the plan nodes
and the plan includes a lot of extra
nodes to represent the intermediate plan
to construct the whole plan
but the basic structure of the of the
analyzed plan is the same as the plant G
I showed before
whereas the optimized plan only contains
20 lines of plan nodes
the optimizer removes the intermediate
extra plants during the optimization
uh one big change here is the joint type
it changed from left join to Inner join
for the calculation of the total amount
inner join is usually much faster than
the outer joints like left joint
what about the physical plan
seems like the planner decided to use
sodma's joint that involves Shuffle
instead of broadcast join for large
inputs at first
by the way spark has so-called adaptive
query execution
that further optimizes the plan even
during the execution
it collects statistics from the
intermediate data and use it to select
more optimal physical plan
during the execution the aqe decided to
use broadcast join rather than sortman's
join because it turned out that the
intermediate data
are intermediate that size is small
enough to fit in the memory
in general broadcast joints can run much
faster than solve much join as it
doesn't need Shuffle of large amount of
data
spark has more and more optimization
than we introduced here
it's still improving and when it becomes
faster pandasone spunk will also become
faster
okay lastly let's say the future of
ponds API and Spark
the upcoming major change is that jvm
will not be necessary in the client side
anymore
currently spark connect project is in
progress the project defines and
implements the protocol based on the
logical plan between the spark cluster
and the client
the spark level in the client side will
only need to talk the protocol and the
plan will be run on the cluster
the spark connector for pi spark data
frame support will be available in spark
3.4 and then
pandasone spark will also be able to run
on spark connect after that
other than that continue increasing API
coverage that is currently about 85
percent
and continue improving performance in
both spark and thunderstorm spark layers
yeah that's it thank you for listening
uh to our talk